you know of course as you talk about the
the role of you the US involvement is of
critical importance here for the United
States and the argument you make is that
we should not be involved in
Ukraine at least to the degree we are we
being the United States uh and we should
not be involved in Israel to the degree
we are because it's stretching us too
thin when uh the big geopolitical
contender in the 21st century with
United States is
China that is that a correct
summary yeah I I think just on Ukraine
we should not have pushed Ukraine to
join NATO sure uh and once the war
started we should have worked overtime
to shut it down immediately March Yeah
March right and and you remember by the
way not to go back to Ukraine in great
detail in the fall early fall of 2022
the war starts February 2022 this March
2022 which we've talked about which is
the negotiations in the fall of 2022 I
think it was in
September uh the ukrainians had won two
major tactical victories one in hiran
and the other in harke and at that point
in time General Millie who was the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
said now is the time to negotiate
because this is the high War Mark for
the ukrainians yeah Billy understood
that things were only going to get worse
and the White House shut Millie down and
said we're not negotiating so we have
blown a number of opportunities here to
head this problem off at the pass uh and
uh but that's my view there and uh with
regard to the Israelis my only point
about Israel is that it would be better
for Israel and better for the United
States if we the United States were in
was in a position the United States was
in a position to put pressure on Israel
from time to time as Steve and I say in
the book we should be able to treat
Israel like a normal country right the
fact is that countries sometimes do
stupid things this includes the United
States and Israel and if Israel is
pursuing a policy that we think is
unwise we should be in a position where
we could put pressure on Israel yeah
that's our argument right but anyway we
goofed both with regard to Ukraine and
with regard to the Middle East and we're
now up to our eyeballs in alligators in
both of those regions and as you
describe my view this is not good
because the area of the most strategic
importance for the United States Today
Is East Asia and that's because China is
there and China is the most serious
threat the United States
faces